this is a production of Cornell
University
hi everyone welcome to the 2023 hemp
webinar series for those of you that
couldn't join us in the last webinar my
name is Luis monsarate I am a second
year PhD student in plant breeding and
genetics in Larry smart slab Alcona
University and once again I'm
accompanied by by Colonel Allen Antonio
who has assisted me during this webinar
together
uh from here on I will start to sound a
little bit like a broken record for
those of you that joined the last
webinar but there are two buttons that
you will be using during this webinar to
interact with us and with the speakers
so the Q a and the chat button that you
see there so please make sure to enter
your questions to the speaker using the
Q a button and those questions will be
answered at the end of the talk any
other dialogue can be done using the
chat button and please feel free to
submit these suggestions uh that you may
have for the Improvement of the series
and once again lastly I just want to
mention that this webinar series is a
component of a larger project which is
the development of eight educational
modules that will be free available on
the Cornell ham website at the end of
the webinar series each of these modules
will consist of the recorded webinar
like this one instructional slide that
with a more of a teaching style of the
subject and a set of high impact papers
putting into the respective subject in
this case this module will be on
propagation of hemp for example
and also all the webinar recordings will
be available on the cornell6 YouTube
channel if you're interested in watching
them or sharing them with someone that
couldn't attend so with that
I would like to introduce our speaker
today's speaker is Dr Mark bridgen he's
a professor of horticulture and plant
breeding genetics akona University
um and since 2002 he has served as a
director of The Long Island
Horticultural research and education
Extension Center excuse me AKA lyrec in
Riverhead New York the topic of his talk
is simply put propagation of hemp so the
division if you like to share your
screen and just take it away okay all
righty good afternoon everybody thank
you for joining us this afternoon to
talk about the propagation of him
uh just a little bit uh about me uh some
of you have noticed that um at um
Cornell's Long Island station
um Cornell has uh a few off-campus
remote locations and we are the farthest
one away we are 300 miles away
uh in Riverhead New York uh in Suffolk
County we are just last year celebrated
our 100th anniversary being here on Long
Island and uh the reason that we had
been down here for so long is we are
here to help the agricultural Community
most people especially most New Yorkers
don't know that Eastern Long Island
actually is the number one county in the
state of New York for crop agriculture
um we used to be number one for total
agriculture now we're down about three I
think but
um anyways we we have more greenhouses
down here more nurseries down here than
anywhere else in the state as well as
over 2 000 Acres of grapes vegetables
and much more so we work with our
stakeholders which are very conveniently
about within a 50-mile radius of us
we were very proud of our 100th
anniversary uh we are the only research
station in the United States uh that has
scientists that represents each of the
commodity Industries we we have
scientists that represent the greenhouse
and floriculture Industry uh the food
industry especially grapes and
viticulture
um we have Specialists for vegetables
and potatoes as well as Woody
ornamentals and Landscape plants in
addition we have cross discipline
Specialists we have two really wonderful
plant Pathologists weed scientists and
an excellent entomologist and also I
Supply the information for plant tissue
culture so we are kind of a One-Stop
shop for everything that our
stakeholders need and they're due there
since they're very close to us we
interact with them quite a bit
as Louise mentioned I I do teach the
plant propagation class at Cornell it's
it's offered this fall semester and um
we cover all all topics about
propagation there's not enough time in
one semester but
um we have Hands-On labs in addition to
the uh lectures to go along with the
education
okay so we're going to talk about plant
propagation today and then for those of
you who are not aware basically all
plant propagation is
multiplying plants it's figured out ways
different ways to multiply plants
increase their numbers either bisexual
techniques or asexual techniques if
you're into uh propagation in the bottom
right this logo is the International
Plant propagator Society you might be
interested in that it's a National
Organization three regions in the United
States eastern western and southern
region and their motto is to seek and
share and they they are always very
willing to share information so if you
really like propagation you might want
to consider that organization
but today we're going to talk about
hemps and hemp plants and how to
propagate them and
um they can be propagated by both sexual
and asexual techniques So today we're
going to cover three main areas
um seed propagation uh for sexual
propagation and then two asexual
propagation techniques we're going to
talk about vegetative cutting
propagation and then um stem cutting and
then also micro propagation okay so stem
cutting propagation is the most commonly
used for hemp uh hemp can be asexually
propagated by other techniques such as
grafting or layering or other techniques
but for stem cutting propagation
um that is the most convenient and most
successful so that's all I'm going to
talk about today and then uh we'll get
into the micro propagation which I'm
very uh proud about because my graduate
students who I'll be showing you later
have really worked out a very detailed
protocol for hemp plants
okay so before we get into specifics
let's talk about some general basics for
propagation
and one of the things to remember is
that healthy plants produce healthy
propagues okay so you want to start off
if you're it's even seeds or cuttings
you want to start off with healthy
mother plants or sometimes they're
called stock plants this this picture on
the right shows a hemp plant that hasn't
been fertilized well you can see it's
yellow it's weak compared to on the
right a hemp plant that's been well
fertilized and well cared for it's very
strong stems would be very good to
generate any kind of cunnings from
in addition to healthy stock plants you
need to consider the media we're going
to actually when we start talking about
stem cuttings
or get into media more detailed but
overall you just want to have a
propagation medium that has good
drainage because you need you need
oxygen in in that Medium so that the
roots can respire well the medium should
be free of any kind of weed seeds or
pathogens and insects it should be able
to wet very easily and then maintain its
moisture and it should also have some
cation exchange capacity in other words
the ability to retain some nutrients so
that when those little plants that would
propagating start to grow that they have
some nutrition that help them grow much
faster
and light's an important consideration
with him because we know that hemp is
photoperiodic right under short days uh
flower buds will initiate and then they
will form and grow when you want to
propagate a plant you want to stay away
from uh floral plants you want to stay
you want to stick with the vegetative
stage of plant growth and so in that
situation they should be growing under
long days and that's much better
especially for taking cuttings we'll
talk a little bit more about that later
and then intensity of course light
intensity is important uh hemp like the
sun they grow well out in the full sun
uh when you move them inside to a
greenhouse they do really well but if
you if you're trying to grow them in a
home environments without any kind of
greenhouse the light intensity can be
quite low and then the plants will
stretch and not grow well and then of
course the wavelength that the plants
receiving you know red light far red
light that sort of thing that's an
important consideration too we're not
going to talk about those today but
these are all things to consider
um one of the most important things when
you're talking about propagation is
water management and humidity whether
it's B seeds or cuttings it doesn't
really matter you need to make sure that
those plants have adequate water and uh
on a large scale an intermittent Mist
system like you see here on the left is
uh nice to use because it automatically
uh will water your cuttings or your
seedlings for you and
if you don't have that kind of system
you can use something very similar like
a plastic covered Dome or even like if
you only have a single plant or a small
number of plants and you want to root
them all you have to do is stick those
cuttings and cover them with a plastic
bag in the plastic bag keeps the
humidity up and for you know cutting
propagation this is important because
you're removing the the plant you're
removing stem cuttings from a mother
plant and they have no roots right and
so you don't want them to transpire
keeping them in a high humidity they're
going to reduce transpiration until the
new Roots form and allow them to take up
their own water from the growing medium
temperature is an important thing with
with hemp they do like uh warm
temperatures uh generally uh the rule of
thumb for for hemp is at least 73
degrees Fahrenheit up to 77 and
oftentimes uh they like much warmer
temperatures and when we get to the
micro propagation part of this
presentation you'll see some temperature
studies that we did and they they really
do demonstrate the their desire for a
warmer temperature
and also cleanliness good sanitation is
important uh we can't Overlook some of
these Basics like good sanitation you
know using clean pots new Pots if
they're used pots they should have been
sanitized
um even inside the greenhouse making
sure that plant debris removed algae is
removed that sort of thing because these
are just those kinds of situations will
um
encourage insects and diseases so you
want to make sure that your growing
facility is very clean
Okay so
if you're trying to decide whether you
want to propagate your plants by seeds
or by some form of asexual propagation
you should remember that hemp plants are
dioecious right so they have male
flowers on one plant and female flowers
on the other plant so they occur in
different plants but mostly for hemp
we're concerned with or interested with
the female flowers right we want them uh
the female flyers for the different
products that we want to extract so
um
remember when you have seed propagation
there is genetic recombination and
segregation of traits and also that
means that there'll be male plants and
female plants produced so if you only
want female plants if you want clones
then you're going to be restricted to
some form of vegetative propagation
Dr Alan Taylor up there in Geneva at
Cornell University uh one of the other
off-campus facilities he's been doing a
lot of work with uh seeds of hemp this
just shows you uh a picture of hemp
seeds as an Akin they're very similar to
a sunflower seed in case you haven't
seen the seeds up close and cleaned
so if you're going to start with seed
propagation of him just like the basics
that I covered a few minutes ago you
have to remember you want to start off
with good healthy seat viable seed good
genetics right the stronger the genetics
you have the better the plants you're
going to grow you may be interested in
feminized seeds if you want just female
seeds
and you also need to understand the
growing media whether it's a field that
you're going to sow the seeds in or some
kind of greenhouse media that media
should be well drained as I mentioned
earlier should be fairly low weed
pressure and have plenty of nutrients
available for the plants to grow in once
they germinate and start to grow if
you're going to do field any kind of
field soil
germination of your seeds uh it's wise
to do a soil test uh this season before
you start planting uh
find out if you need to adjust the pH or
add any kind of nutrients
and you also should think strategically
if you're going to plan out in the field
uh so that you can maximize your
environment uh considered frost date
right you want to plant after the last
frost date because you don't want your
seeds to come up and then get frosted
luckily in the spring when the
temperatures start to warm up our day
lengths are getting longer so we have
long days and that's very very good for
hemp growth and then um consider the
rain you may want to plant your your
seeds a day or two before rain is
predicted so that they get watered in
really well this is especially important
if you don't have an irrigation source
so when you're going to propagate your
seeds one thing you can do to help
improve your success is to soak the
seeds in water for anywhere from eight
to twelve hours uh before you sow the
seeds Okay this this allows the seeds to
imbibe the water and then start the
whole germination process right enzymes
start breaking down things you know
lipids and fats breaking down so
um the whole germination process begins
and gives you a little bit of Head Start
it sometimes makes it a little more
complicated when you're sowing the seeds
but remember soaking the seeds
pre-soaking your seeds is is helpful but
it's really not necessary for him
and then temperature again is very
important for seed germination a minimal
temperature of 65 and warmer is better
so anywhere over 65 degrees would be
great
um you can plant your seeds about an
inch deep under the the median
um small back in 2016 had a paper
showing that uh hemp seeds did not
matter if it was light or dark
conditions so they don't seem to be
affected by light or or the absence of
light
and then lastly don't forget very
important that once you get your seeds
sown make sure you water them thoroughly
because this starts the germination
process and we'll get them going they
have good water source
Dr Taylor and his team up in Geneva did
some work with seed size and found out
that larger seeds uh will have a better
germination rate than the smaller seeds
so when you're if you especially if
you're involved with breeding uh you
might look at your seedling offsprings
and see you know you can just visually
tell if they're going to be good uh
germinators or not just by the size of
the seeds
they also did a bunch of work with uh
storing seeds and found that really hemp
seeds do not have a long storage life
about a year and a half
um is best for them to be stored and
after that their viability decreases
very significantly so if you're if
you're producing hemp seed make sure
that you're using it within a year year
and a half
okay
um if you're
more interested in producing clones than
uh we're going to look at vegetative
propagation and this is a way that you
can get clones they they are an exact
copy of the plant from which they were
taken this maintains their genetic
characteristics as well as their
phenotype so if you um
you wanted only female plants you can
get only female plants if that's what
you propagate from and the other
advantage of vegetative propagation is
that you can get many cuttings from a
single plant
and as I mentioned you can get all
female plants too if that's what your
your objective is your cuttings
um when you've vegetatively propagate a
hemp plant can be very uniform which is
helpful for doing research as well as
just for your growing purposes and it's
low cost now I won't say it's less
expensive than seed propagation because
seed propagation is the least expensive
but remember if you go with seed
propagation you don't necessarily get
all female plants here if you asexually
propagate a plant you're going to get
clones and that's what a lot of people
are looking for
in addition if you take cuttings and get
clones through vegetative propagation
your plants are going to be stronger and
they're going to kind of have a head
start compared to seedlings which are
weak when they start when they germinate
and they start to grow plants come from
mature plants and once they get the
roots in 10 to 14 days they're ready to
go
the other nice thing about vegetative
propagation is that you can if you have
a greenhouse or some kind of indoor
production facility you can get
year-round production
so we're going to talk primarily about
stem cuttings today this is the most
common approach to vegetatively
propagate hemp plants and basically a
cutting is just a piece of the plant
that has been removed from the mother
plant and then given the opportunity to
make its own roots and grow as an
individual plant this is one way you can
get a clone it's the identical plant as
the stock plant from which it was taken
foreign
very simple you don't need any high-tech
tools to propagate plants
um basically a sharp knife or some
striped Clippers or a razor blade they
can all be used to take your cuttings
um remember that your your tools should
be clean and disinfested simply with
maybe a 95 ethanol or a bleach solution
if if you're worried that they were used
for on other plants that may have
carried diseases
um we're going to talk about a
propagation medium and a meat in a
minute but we'll need a medium you need
a rooting hormone we're recommending uh
hormone one or any of the uh any of the
brands that have about 0.1 percent IBA
that's about a thousand parts per
million
um you know they come these other
rooting hormones they come in stronger
concentrations here you know you can see
it's it's point three or three thousand
parts per million or 8 000 parts per
million you don't really need that level
of oxen a very low 1000 parts per
million level is fine for for rooting
hemp cuttings and then you'll need some
kind of technique to keep your plants
moist either humidity Dome or an
intermittent Mist system
and then
um you want to take your clones from
mature plants these are plants at least
two months old just as a general rule of
thumb you don't want to take cuttings
from very young immature plants because
the cuttings are going to be weak that
you won't get strong plants from them
and also a mature plant a larger plant's
going to give you many more cuttings
than
um than a small plant will do
so remembering that hemp is a
photoperiodic plant
um you want to and also remembering that
you want to take your cuttings from
healthy plants uh you want to make sure
that uh they're not in flour now it's
not impossible to to take cuttings from
um a flowering hemp plant in fact my
very first experience some years ago was
to take cuttings from
um flowering hemp plants clones that
from Dr Smart's breeding program up
there he wanted to take some cuttings
and they worked fine and all you have to
do all you have to remember when you're
taking cuttings from flowering plants is
that the cuttings should be placed under
long days so
um you know take them to the greenhouse
make sure the lights are on at least 16
hours a day and this will help the the
process of rooting and also it would
help to remove the flower buds and any
seeds that are on there that that way
all the energy from that cutting is
going to root formation but if you want
to make your life easy just take your
cuttings from vegetative plants and they
will root very readily for you
and don't forget I have a liberal
asterisk down here don't forget to label
your cuttings if you're if you're taking
cuttings from different cultivars or
different kinds of hemp plants uh make
sure you label them because once they
start growing if you don't have labels
you might forget which ones you have
so Dr James Faust down at Clemson
University has been doing some work with
Alex Carver on nutrition of hemp plants
and they were they have an interesting
study here they were looking at stock
plants that were fertilized with three
different levels of nitrogen 100 200 and
300 parts per million and
um briefly what they found is that stock
plants that were receiving the higher
levels of fertilizer the 200 and 300
parts per million nitrogen grew much
better much stronger plants and then
produced more cuttings than a plant that
received either no nutrition or very low
nutrition
um when you're taking your cuttings you
it's best to choose the apical cuttings
from the stock plants that doesn't need
that nodal cuttings won't work uh it
just means that apical cuttings uh they
have a growing point they're ready to go
once the roots are formed they they they
just take off and grow quickly so
generally we recommend apical cuttings
and uh having at least two or three
nodes on the plants and generally if
they're depending on
uh your plant it's about a cutting of
about five inches up to eight inches in
length
once you take your cutting just like any
other plant you want to remove any of
the lower leaves on that cutting the on
the section of the cutting that's going
to be below the propagation medium
because if there are leaves down there
and you stick it in the propagation
meaning it's a white a wet moist medium
um there's a good chance that those
leaves were rot anyways so just remove
them before you stick your cuttings and
if you have a situation where the leaves
on the top of the plant are very large
and um you know they they cause the
cutting to flop over because of the
weight don't be afraid to take your
scissors and trim those leaves off okay
um trimming the leaves down a little bit
so that you have more manageable space
is not going to hurt that cutting uh we
know that you know leaves on a cutting
do help uh that cutting root uh but
you're not removing the leaves by any
means you're just kind of reducing them
by one-third or one-half so uh take off
the lower leaves and trim the the large
leaves if necessary
and then you want to gently wound the
bottom of the cutting again this is one
of those things that is not 100
necessary for a success but it's it's
definitely going to increase your uh the
speed of rooting by just taking your
knife and making a slight wound uh
sometimes that process of just removing
the lower leaves when you break that
Pedro off the stem that's enough
wounding uh for the cutting to succeed
and then you want to treat it with the
rooting powder we're recommending about
a point one percent IBA that's a
thousand part per million as I mentioned
earlier so you would take your cutting
wound it dip it in some water and then
dip it into your rooting powder and then
take that
um cutting that has the hormone on it
and stick it into the rooting medium
again Dr Faust and Alex Carver did some
work on oxens and uh they looked at
um IBA and NAA two different auxins at
uh four different levels either none two
thousand four thousand to six
thousandths part per million and they
found out that the best rooting was at
about two thousand to four thousand
parts per million either IBA or NAA
and um you might notice or might
remember that this 2000 part per million
is a lot is about twice the amount that
I recommended earlier but uh there is a
difference because in this research at
Clemson they were using a liquid dip
that's in other words that's the oxen
that was dissolved into water and then
uh previously when I was talking about
the 1000 part per million I was
referring to
um a powder dip so there is a difference
based on the application procedure and
also on their research they looked at
seven different cultivars and they found
out that there were differences amongst
the cultivars as far as the results of
This research which is makes sense
because we all know that genetics play
uh an important part of how plants react
and so we would expect that uh some
cultivars would root better at some
levels and some cultivars would root
worse
so earlier I mentioned propagation
medium and this is a very
um confusing discussion for a lot of
people because they don't you know that
if you go on online and look for rooting
medium these are the options that you
have and it could be overwhelming if
you're not very familiar with
propagation but here you know in the top
Center here's your basic 50 50 medium of
peat moss and perlite it's an industry
standard people love that for rooting
almost any kind of cutting but it
doesn't need to be perlite you could be
per it could be vermiculite as you see
here those are both components that give
you good drainage that's why you have a
50 50 peat moss and whatever because the
peat moss offers the water retention
where the perlite or the vermiculite
will give you good drainage there are
other a lot of different options out
there too in the top right are these
Jiffy pellets which are great use you
soak them in water for a short period of
time and then you stick your seat or
your cutting in an oasis foam that
nowadays coconut core is is a very
common propagation tool we've we've
tested that in our propagation class and
found coconut core to be very very good
because of the drainage if it's managed
right but Campbell at all back in 2021
found that rock wool in their situation
uh offered a 7 to 13
times improvement over the next uh best
rooting medium so
um it's best if you try different
options for your rooting and find out
which works best for your situation it
makes a difference on how how humid your
plant is or how humid your Greenhouse is
uh your watering techniques that sort of
thing so but these are all
um
feasible techniques that you can stick
your cuttings
and as we mentioned before high humidity
is is very important
um once you stick your cuttings because
um again those cuttings don't have any
Roots they're not able to take water up
from the roots and from The Medium so
you want to make sure that the leaves
stay moist and they stay detergent the
stomachs remain closed so they don't
transpire and um like the seeds you
could use a plastic Dome if you wanted
to or just a plastic bag or in the
intermittent mist is a very good
automatic system which is used worldwide
successfully
and the temperature for for hemp
cuttings generally uh on the warmer side
of around 75 degrees plus or minus
um 72 at the lowest and
um and then a lot of people prefer to
use some kind of root Zone heating as
you see here on the bottom there's
there's heat mats all kinds of different
heat mats and heat systems that you can
use but generally remember the
um it's the root temperature it's the
medium temperature that's more important
than the air temperature so if you want
to save some money on heating your
Greenhouse don't worry about keeping the
greenhouse warm just worry about keeping
the roots of those plants warm and
either these heating Maps mats are
possible or some greenhouses they run
their heating pipes underneath the
benches so that the benches are warmer
than the air
so temperature is very important with
with hemp because they do like it warm
so let's let's move into
um the last part of this discussion
we're going to talk about micro
propagation which is a part of plant
tissue culture uh plant tissue culture
if you're not familiar it's just
essentially growing plants on some kind
of a sterile nutrient medium in vitro
under controlled conditions there are a
lot of different things you can do with
plant tissue culture for us breeders you
know we use embryo rescue we use
mutation breeding we use anthraculture
we use all kinds of things you can do
with tissue culture but for this
discussion today for him we're going to
talk about micro propagation which
essentially like taking stem cuttings
that I previously talked about but in
this situation the plants are in a
sterile environment
um in vitro
these are um The Graduate students that
worked on this project were very happy
that our paper has been accepted into
court science it's either going to be
published next month or the following
month uh we're going to have the cover
of the hoard science uh issue and um
this is Victor zayez from left to right
Victor zayas who's a PhD student Connor
Steven who got his master's as well as
Andre gallach who got his Masters
they're they're both gone Victor is
still in the laboratory
so why would you decide to use micro
propagation instead of one of the
previous techniques well like
um stem cutting propagation clonal
propagation is very important this is
the way you're going to get identical
plants to the mother plants clones right
um you're also going to have very clean
rigorous plant material if they're grown
in the sterile environment they don't
have fungi they don't have bacteria
you can grow a lot of plants in a very
small space so it's very efficient for
space utilization large numbers small
space that's great that makes for high
efficiency and high profits and it's
also less maintenance instead of hauling
around 10 gallon pots or five gallon
pots that are heavy and cumbersome
you're working in a laboratory with very
small
items
and just like with the stem cutting
propagation if you had a greenhouse you
could do it all year round in a tissue
culture lab again you do that all year
round too because it's a controlled
environment the plants um don't care if
it's snowing outside or not so um and we
can consider our plants to be disease
free remember just by stage one of of
micro propagation which we'll talk about
in a minute it cleans off all the fungi
and the bacteria
um we're not sure about viruses but you
can have your plants tested and if they
are virus free when you put them into
tissue culture they will continue to be
virus free so then you have a totally
pathogen free plant which is one of the
big advantages for micro propagation
so these are the stages of micro
propagation that that our our team
worked on uh for the last two years
um we we kind of used uh we used one
cultivar the TJ CBD
um and we looked at all different stages
and multiple aspects of each state so
stage stage zero is uh growing a healthy
stock plant a healthy mother plant if we
have hopefully it's free from insects
and diseases as possible growing well in
a well-lit location with plenty of
nutrients
stage one is where you introduce your
plant material uh from the whole plant
into in vitro and um let them grow
aseptically
stage two is the multiplication phase
when you're increasing numbers of plants
uh this is a situation where normally in
a commercial laboratory they would
subculture these every four weeks they
would take these plants out of the
culture vessel chop them up into a
number of new plants and then
reintroduce them into new new vessels on
Fresh medium
and then lastly stage three and four is
rooting an acclimation
um I'll give you a spoiler alert uh our
final conclusions found out that we
don't really need stage three with hemp
you can go directly from stage two to
stage four but I'll show you why we came
to that conclusion
so these are the different things that
We examined in our paper I'm not going
to show data or anything like that if
you want to get more details email me
and I can send you a copy of the the
paper or wait it's going to like I said
it's going to be in word science either
next month or the month after but we
looked at the nutrients that the plants
were receiving we looked at the sugars
that they received uh the gelling agents
that made it a semi-solid uh compound
and then also the plant growth
Regulators that they received in the
medium
and then we also looked at the explant
type uh what kind of cuttings that we
took off the mother plant we looked at
the temperature that they were grown in
as well as the pH of the medium
so stage one uh
can be complicated for some people and
we've had a lot of people contact us
saying they just can't get their plant
material in in vitro so we set up these
studies uh in you know Common old
household bleach is used to clean off
pet materials for stage one
um nowadays bleach comes in different
concentrations we use the 7.5 sodium
hypochloride and we did 20 40 and 60
levels for 10 minutes
and then we use these these treatments
um with plants that were removed from
either the greenhouse up here or from a
growth chamber situation just to see
what kind of uh results we would get
well it was very interesting that all
the uh
cuttings that we took from the growth
from plants that were grown in a growth
chamber it didn't matter if it was 20 40
or 60 bleach they were almost all clean
whereas the the cuttings that we took
from plants grown in the greenhouse were
almost all contaminated
um which kind of makes sense because
Greenhouse plants are dirtier there's a
lot of different
um fungi bacteria you know different
kinds of pathogens in a greenhouse than
there is in a growth chamber so we
concluded the plant material that's
grown in the growth chamber has a much
better success chance for Success than
plants that are grown in a greenhouse
and even though we didn't examine it in
this study we can also pretty
confidently conclude that if either one
of these techniques is better than
taking plant material from a field
because from field plants because field
grown plants are really dirty so if you
want to increase your chance of success
use stock plants that are in a protected
area like a growth chamber
um we also found out that it didn't
matter if we used 20 or 60 bleach they
all worked on plants that were grown
from a growth chamber so they all worked
well and interestingly even the highest
concentration the 60 percent of bleach
did not damage the plant material it
suggests that we could even if we wanted
to use a you know higher levels of
bleach 100 maybe we didn't try that but
at 60 percent bleach no damage kind of
tells us that hemp are pretty tolerant
of bleach
for stage two we had several experiments
one was looking at nutrient medium here
we compared uh murushugi and skug medium
which is kind of the industry standard
Ms to linsmeyer skoog uh dkw Medium as
well as Lloyd and McCown's wpm medium
and essentially there was no difference
between the MS LS or the dkw medium hemp
plants seem to grow well in any one of
those three however plants grown in wpm
medium just were not healthy they did
not grow well
um you know wpm medium is used for a lot
of the arocatious plants rhododendrons
Mount Laurels Heats and Heathers that
sort of thing their their nitrogen
requirements are different and so the
nitrogen levels in wpm are different and
that must be the reason why hemp it was
not very happy there
we also looked at cytokinase
the two uh commercial cytokines ba and
two IP were our primary interest but we
also checked uh we also trial diodiazem
which has cytokine-like activity because
again if you look online at papers and
comments that people make they say that
they've used iodiazeron successfully but
we we used all three of these cytokinins
at 1 5 and 10 Micro levels
and here you can see that
um the plants did very well with ba and
2ip and that asron was interesting
um if you looked at the fresh weight the
plants growing the fire to Ezra and had
a greater fresh rate and they also had
the greater number of nodes like here on
the the bottom right of these two you
can see many many dozens of shoots and
you might think well then this must be
the best medium because it has the most
number of shoots well it's not
um they're not healthy shoots they're
shorter they're um compact they don't
have as many nodes and maybe the biggest
problem with using that asron is that it
produces callus tissue if you want to
micropropagate a plant you want to avoid
callous because callus production will
increase your chance of a spontaneous
mutation very high so you're going to
avoid callus at all costs so we'll
recommend that you use either the ba or
the two IP as your cytokine and when
you're micro propagating
um
hemp at the lower levels and it works
very well
we also looked at sugar levels from zero
sugar all the way up to 60 grams per
liter sugar the industry standard is
about 30 grams per liter most people
grow using Ms medium use 30 grams per
liter sugar but we found in these
studies that both 15 grams per liter and
30 grams per liter produced equally nice
plants the same kind of high fresh rate
and length and shoot production in
addition to 15 grams per liter the lower
level showed less hyperhydricity
um so we're recommending either 15 or 30
grams per liter of sugar especially if
you're going to do the 15 grams per
liter you'd have to stick to a four week
subculture cycle because after four
weeks that sugar is used up
we also looked at gelling agents uh we
looked at agar which is commonly used uh
comparing it to a gel and gum that's
like a fighter gel or a gel right or
some of the commercial names and then
also a 50 50 mix of the auger and the
Joan and essentially we didn't find any
differences so any one of these could be
used
we also looked at pH in the medium all
the way from a low acidic pH of four all
the way up to seven typically most uh if
people use emerging skilled medium have
about a 5.8 pH and we found that five
point and higher were fine there were no
differences they still produced
um good healthy plants good fresh weight
and so we're recommending just stick
with the 5.8 because that's what most
Labs use anyways but you could go higher
if you wanted to but there's no
advantages to going higher
in a very interesting experiment that we
did we looked at temperature uh from as
low as 72 degrees up to 82 degrees and
it was very clear that the warmer
temperatures the two warmer temperatures
79 and 82 the plants did much much
better they grew faster they did
significant fresh weight increase and
very well so you should remember to keep
your plants in vitro at least about 79
degrees or warmer
uh for stage three we looked at auxins
we looked at NAA and IBA at different
levels and
um at 2.5 0.5 or 0.25 micro mole and
um the we're recommending the IBA uh for
best shoot growth at the 2.5 micro mole
level uh NAA did well they it rooted
well and so but there was callus
produced and again as I mentioned
earlier we want to avoid callus if
possible
and then into stage four the acclimation
stage which is very important because
micro propagated plants don't have any
uh waxy cuticle on the leaves and you
don't want them to desiccate we compared
two systems of the intermittentness
system in the greenhouse uh versus just
a regular plastic Dome and then we
um doubled this
experiment and used either with uh
external
application of oxen or no oxen and we
found out that the Dome definitely did
better than the
the intermittent Mist it's probably
because of the amount of water that was
present on the leaves but the Dome
plants did well and auxins did okay but
there was no significant advantage to
using oxen's uh over non-oxins so save
the time save the labor save the money
don't use an oxen but if it makes you
feel better go ahead and use it but no
advantage
so in summary
um just make sure you have a good clean
environments for the mother plants you
can use a variety of media stay away
from wpm media uh you can use as low as
15 grams per liter sucrose 30 grams is
probably fine keep your temperatures
warmer side 26 to 28 uh there are
different cytokines you can use that
seem to work fine and stage three is not
necessary you can go directly from stage
two to stage four and even though we
found good results with IBA it's really
not necessary and then when you want to
harden them off plastic domes seem to do
a better job than an intermittent Mist
system
and as I mentioned earlier auxins help
um but they're not necessary for that
stage four
and lastly the gelling agent and pH
appear to have little impact on the
growth of tissue culture plants
so um I'm close to my 45 minutes here so
I uh I'll stop here I just want to again
recognize the students who did uh
the majority of the work for this uh
Conor Victor and Andre and then we also
had an undergrad Victoria Zhang that
helped us and this photo here is uh a
picture of our hemp plants from tissue
culture they were in vitro for two years
we took them out rooted them grew them
out the field in the field to see if
there were any kind of phenotypic
differences and there were none so they
grew healthy and they grew well even
though when they're propagated from
tissue culture
so I think
um at that point I'll stop sharing and
see if we have some questions
so the question is can you comment on
somatic mutation accumulation in clonal
or tissue culture produced plants
um so uh this question from Nicholas I
think what you're asking is
um is are there phenotypic differences
the longer you keep a plant in tissue
culture and um
yes theoretically
um I mean obviously for these studies
that we did they were only short term
but
um but with other plant materials we
know that
um commercially commercial micro
propagators really need to refresh their
their plant material after a year or two
even so that they maintain those
characteristics because
um plants do change over time in tissue
culture
um and as you mentioned it's a good way
to avoid mutations
can you comment on somatic mutation
accumulation in uh tissue culture plants
um like I said
um if you want to avoid mutations you
need to make sure that your mother
plants your stock plants are refreshed
frequently like you know there's no set
rule but a year two years you know you
don't want to keep your cultures five
years ten years because what happens is
they don't necessarily all mutate but
what will happen is you might get one
mutation
um
occurring and then then you propagate it
you know so then as you as you go
through and you you go through stage two
and multiply your plants if you have a
mutation you could very well propagate
that mutation
uh rooting hormone for certified organic
I assume that's for a stem cutting
um
I can't answer that question I'm sorry
about that for a rooting hormone
I mean um
IAA
in the celic acid is a natural hormone
and um that I
that might qualify as certified Organics
since it's natural but I'm not
um I'm not up on the rules for certified
organic but but I think you can find
natural toxins if that is sufficient to
make you certified
do root Riot cubes work
um I don't know about root right cubes I
haven't seen any comparison with him on
that
uh which growing medium is recommended
to grow Greenhouse again it's it's up to
you there are a lot of good media out
there
um you know
basically a 50 50 peat moss per light or
50 50 peat moss and very make light
works fine but any of the bagged
commercial medians now pro-mix uh Jiffy
Mix I mean all those they make great
media and I would recommend you try a
few on your plants and see what works
best for you and then also you know
economics is involved too some people
look at the price
um
more questions about the certified
organic
is there any research using
electromagnetic magnetism magnetism to
grow um not that I am aware of I'm not
that word
do you have recommendations for the
control of endophytes in tissue culture
um oh yes sometimes they see the
emergence of a systemic bacteria yes we
had that problem at the very beginning
when we started this whole research we
were taking cuttings from Greenhouse
plants that were existed already in the
greenhouses and we had a lot of systemic
uh pathogens
um actually one of the co-authors one of
my grandsons Victor zayas who who was on
this work is
um just meticulous about making sure
there are cleaned uh plant material and
he was noticing a lot of systemic
pathogens bacteria and so um
that's one of the reasons why we decided
to go to uh plants that were grown in a
growth chamber because they were they
were you know
planted in fresh uh clean medium and
clean pots and we didn't have that
um it is a problem I would suggest you
try other plants if you can't try other
plants you can actually considering the
the tolerance of hemp to the bleach
concentration you can actually try to
keep your cuttings in the bleach longer
and allow the bleach to soak through the
stems longer and you might be able to
remove those systemic pathogens we have
actually done that not with him but with
other plants that we had and each time
we subcultured actually we would dip
them into a bleach solution and then
subculture and over time after about
three or four subcultures we eliminated
the pathogens
where these trials run on meristem
tissue uh no these would run on stem
segments little stem segments and again
the question is is there carryover
bacteria from the mother plant there can
be that's why it's important to um
starting with clean plant material
can you say conclusively that tissue
culture plants are immune from thyroid
oh I conclusively say no they're not
immune just because a plant is tissue
culture doesn't mean it's any less
susceptible so once you take that plant
out of tissue culture if it's virus free
if you take it out of tissue culture and
you plan it out in the field or plant it
in your greenhouse and then it gets bit
by a leaf Hopper or some other insect
carrying the virus it will get the virus
so um that's a good question because
just because the plant is tissue culture
doesn't mean that it's resistant to
viruses or virus in this case
um it just means that they're clean at
the time of propagation
the next question is what is bottleneck
of micro propagation uh what's the
bottleneck
um I I guess the bottleneck is if you
have a large number of plants that you
need to produce or you want to produce
um and you're limited with space under
your lights the grow lights where you're
growing your tissue cultures that's
going to be the bottleneck and
scheduling is one of the more difficult
things that commercial Labs have to do
because if they have to produce a
hundred thousand plants for a certain
customer but they only have room for ten
thousand this is just an example they
have to make sure that they can rotate
properly in that um
in their growth room so that they can
produce the the amount of plants that
they need in the time they need
um so I think if there's a bottleneck
that that might be it
seed feminine feminization
um
I'm not the person to ask about that so
I think maybe one of the other speakers
down the future might be
um is there any risk growers in Growers
conduction micro propagation without the
resources to a genetic testing
um if you so basically I think what this
question is saying is
um
do we worry about mutations thermoclonal
variation is mutation that occurs in
tissue culture and I I think what this
question is asking is should we be
worried about it and is there a way to
test for it and um
I I guess we always should be worried
about it but if you do the protocol
correctly remember you're taking clones
you're taking organized growing points
and you're allowing them to grow
in individual
um
if you start with an organized growing
point and you subculture correctly
making sure there's no callous
production or if there is callous
production that you eliminate it quickly
um you should not have genetic mutations
no you should not have somoclonal
variations
um and so I think rather than worrying
about genetic testing I think maybe what
you should focus on is your protocol
your procedure to do it correctly in the
first place and you won't have that
genetic variation
can you grow CBD along with CBG
uh
I haven't tried it but I mean I must I
don't know what that's asking actually
asking does that mean
were the procedures that we're using for
CBD hemp I assume so I don't know
can you cite papers regarding levels for
various stages of growth sufficiently
levels
um
I'm not sure what a sufficiency level is
um so no I can't
interesting question
um what is the time frame from stage one
to stage four we get that question a lot
and that's a hard question to ask
because it depends on how many plants
you're producing at stage two
um if you're talking about just going
through from stage one to stage four
directly for one plant
um
you're going to put your plan in stage
one for four weeks subculture on the
stage two for maybe eight weeks for it
to grow
and then on to stage four so
theoretically you can do it as fast as
three months although uh usually that's
not the case
Paul asks us how long can clones taken
from other plants be grown under lights
before being acclimated without shocking
them
um okay just like any other plant uh
hemp or tomato or whatever plant you're
growing if they're growing indoors under
uh artificial lights you can move them
outside uh but you do need to harden
them off by gradually increasing the
light intensity so um
so how long does it take
um I'd say a week to 10 days you can
Harden them off pretty quickly
uh Karen asks have you seen a variation
in cannabinoid concentration uh we don't
we don't do any work with testing
cannabinoid concentrations so I can't
answer that
meal plants have male flowers and female
plants have meat female flowers that's
what dioces is
uh Jack is asking is any work being done
at our Research Center regards to hemp
breeding
um focusing on second secondary uh
cannabinoids no we are not doing any of
that all the breeding work is up in
Geneva with Larry Smart's team so you
may want to check with Larry smart and
his team up there George stack in that
whole group
um John asks is there a good way to
determine when to remove the humidity
dome in the propagation process
um we have found that our micro
propagated plants as well as regular
stem cuttings root pretty quickly
um 10 days to 14 days so
um I would look after a week I would
open up the Dome just pull out a few
cuttings and see see if there's roots on
them
um and then when you open them up that's
going to allow some of the humidity out
which is fine and help decrease the
chance of any kind of molds so
um I think the best way is that once you
have root initiation then you don't have
to worry about the Dome so much
um remember research a long time ago
found out that it only takes 24 hours
for a plant to regrow its waxy cuticle
from tissue culture it's a very fast
process uh Ellen Sutter did that work
way back in the 80s so once you take a
tissue culture plants out it's uh it's
only about 24 hours until the the waxy
cuticles there
uh Colleen asks about Willow water I
don't know anything about Willow water
sorry
uh can tissue culture media be used for
starting seeds yes definitely but
um most of the media that I mentioned
today especially the most union medium
are very high salts and so what you want
to do is to maybe well not maybe but do
reduce the salt levels if you're using
uh tissue culture media by down to 25
percent we we will germinate seeds in
merge again skilled medium at 25 percent
um
levels so yes you can germinate seeds
and they're pretty easy actually
um Amy asks are there recommendations
other than bleach for stage one uh if
you don't
yeah you can use hydrogen peroxide you
can use ethanol low levels of ethanol
they they work as well as bleach ethanol
you have to be a little more careful
because it fixes cells right it kills
cells so but it can be done
uh Tom asks what agencies or services
are available to individuals in New York
for establishing a micro propagation
facility there's no agencies but I'm
here to help that's part of my job is an
extension so drop me an email Tom I'll
be glad to work with you
um
what types of indoor outdoor research is
most needed
uh Trevor you tell us that's what we're
here to do the work you tell us what you
want us to do
uh Colleen asks about cross breeding I
don't do any breeding I just do the
tissue culture so Larry Smart's the guy
to talk to
um what type of lining uh we use regular
fluorescent lights we don't use LED
lights
um Colleen asks are there commercial
Farms we can see tissue culture work
um yes up in Ithaca there's
um
what's the name of that business there's
a tissue culture lab in Ithaca uh that
um
I can't think I can't remember what the
name is but there is a tissue culture
lab up there Ryan
um
I can't remember his last name but there
is a lab in Ithaca uh there aren't too
many commercial labs in New York
Trevor asks what Greenhouse or
hydroponic research is needed
um I think there's a lot of interest in
Hydroponics uh Dr Neil Matson up in
Ithaca has a great program in
Hydroponics I'm not sure if he's doing
any uh hemp or not but uh he's he's the
great resource he's the best in the
country
uh Jeff asks do you have lighting
intensity recommendations
um
I don't have those figures on the tip of
my tongue but I can help you with that
Jeff if you drop me an email
there's a lot of questions here
um Cindy uh Sicily asks can a plant
flowered under the in vitro conditions
yes it can fly in the tube and it's
really cool when you see it uh we've had
we had that happen during our research
and uh it's interesting and we were kind
of confused because they were growing
under long days so
are viruses transmittable through seeds
yes definitely it depends on the virus
not all viruses are transmitted through
seeds but there are some
Ted asks has any research done with
biostimulants or microfiber or
mycorrhizae fungi
um not to my knowledge there may be but
I don't know that
Rina
Rina nice to see you
um
Rena asks are the protocols Universal
for cannabis are they cultivar specific
well good question Rina we did all this
research with one cultivar to reduce
that variable of genetics so we we did
TJ's CBT on all this research uh but and
I would expect I suspect that there are
going to be differences for different
cultivars and different genetics but
this gives you a foundation of where to
begin where you can start your program
uh but just like everything else not
only in tissue culture or hemp you know
other plants we know that genetics makes
a difference so uh there might be some
tweaking you need with this protocol
and Marcus asks have you noticed any
benefits in seed production from micro
propagation
um we haven't really gone that far no
sorry
and Optimum time to transplant Outdoors
down here Karen on Long Island uh our
last frost free date is about March uh
May 15th it's early
um so we we could plant it by the end of
May
I think up in Ithaca I don't know where
you're located but
um colder climates you might have to
wait longer
so I think Luis I think that's it
yep uh the session was supposed to end
at 3 P.M but I think they had a they
were very interesting questions that I
actually wanted to uh
wanted to see answers so I'm very happy
that there's a lot of participation by
all the attendees so with that I
concludes our webinar for today and
please uh join us in two weeks actually
February 22nd to talk about military
management uh under inter conditions or
indoor cultivation
by Dr Neil Bernstein so thank you so
much Dr vision and thank you all of you
for joining this webinar today
thank you everybody have a nice day
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at cornell.edu